for us obviously with standup is like
right now we're giving everything away
for free on youtube how do we find a way
to monetize these things because making
a [ __ ] special is expensive you know
cost hundreds of thousands you know this
it cost hundreds of thousands of dollars
to make a great quality special right
you can't make that if you're going to
give it away for free so how do you find
a way to monetize it is this the way
maybe but there's going to be ways where
we can do it and then deliver it right
to the people
people support it there's laws in oregon
uh where people pay to uh end their life
end of life what's it called you you
it's euthanasia
assisted suicide euthanasia yeah i want
to do a special and i'm not even kidding
in oregon where we take a bunch of
people that want to die yeah and put
them in a theater whereas after my
special is over
we kill them all right but not kid they
wanted that you did this in portland i'm
dead serious i would shoot every one of
you yeah yeah like as i would be
execution